We have to believe
that we can be better.
To help people understand
their full potential.
It's something in me
that I can’t, turn it off.
Why did I start this
in the first place?
I think it's passion,
empathy.
The belief that
we'll make the world
a better place.
That I have a role,
and that everyone has a role.
Having that hope,
is really what
keeps people going.
I believe that everybody's
given a gift,
but it's just up to us
to decide how we want to use it.
Building the strengths
that make the problems obsolete.
You've got to do
everything within your power now
to be the best you.
You have to look,
you know, beyond yourself.
You can never let
your circumstances define you,
make sure they
always inform you.
We fail all the time.
Biggest thing is
to try to get back up,
and once you're up,
to keep going.
We define ourselves
in our own words
and our own ways.
That's optimism.